Caption: okay so we have had an absolutely
Caption: fantastic bunch of speakers this morning
Caption: ready five so probably have some yeah
Caption: it's been great
Caption: welcome welcome this is probably the
Caption: second biggest turnout again we've had
Caption: all day from mechanical Rock so just a
Caption: quick there is a mix here somewhere and
Caption: concisely as I can so that's not for me
Caption: please a very very big welcome hello
Caption: everyone I can sleep through this pop so
Caption: today we're going to talk about how are
Caption: you going to build you know so I think
Caption: we just want to thank our sponsor
Caption: without whom none of this is possible so
Caption: just a bit about myself my name is
Caption: Williams the main reason I'm here is
Caption: because my boss said bro you need to be
Caption: more active in the community I have
Caption: certification and one vacation yet today
Caption: in the morning I forgot to take off my
Caption: glasses when I just
Caption: so let's start with a problem so this is
Caption: an actual picture of our user when using
Caption: our progressive web apps so one of the
Caption: most interesting requirement that we
Caption: have is the main user of our progressive
Caption: web apps is a technician who so imagine
Caption: typing a complex password using the
Caption: particular dog and the device that they
Caption: used to access the apps will not be
Caption: brought back to the headquarters for a
Caption: couple of months
Caption: so how do you apply update into your
Caption: application actually that's the one of
Caption: the easiest win that we have because
Caption: progressive web app is for web apps you
Caption: don't have to submit editing to the App
Caption: Store or the Android store whatever if
Caption: they have a metal connection and they
Caption: access your web app you always get the
Caption: latest version right so that so just
Caption: could be recap because this is not an
Caption: introduction section progressive web app
Caption: is a web app that reliable it should
Caption: work in any network condition it should
Caption: be fast it should render less than 60
Caption: frames per second and then it should be
Caption: engaging that means the real-time
Caption: notification right so say when people
Caption: talk about progressive web apps they
Caption: talk about service worker which is
Caption: pretty much a proxy on your browser
Caption: right so one of the thing that we learn
Caption: is please do not write the service will
Caption: water yourself so this is typically what
Caption: you write when you're writing so you
Caption: have to define all the assets that you
Caption: own location right and then you have to
Caption: actually write the code that do your
Caption: casing casing strategy whether it's a
Caption: network first or a casebook site it
Caption: really takes a lot of effort to be able
Caption: to write all this and it is a backpack
Caption: for system computer guess all the power
Caption: changes every time we do build so you
Caption: have to redo it all over again every
Caption: time you do a deployment so you should
Caption: miss plugin this one from Google which
Caption: is a Google box or that's the one that
Caption: we use is for Oakland Fagin so all the
Caption: stuff that you see privately we just
Caption: live in this
Caption: and what good about it is you can simply
Caption: say my response ready is never put what
Caption: that mean is it always try to scratch
Caption: the assets from the network before try
Caption: location possible do not write your
Caption: submission by yourself if you don't have
Caption: to
Caption: and secondly do not maintain so this is
Caption: your typical react with Redux
Caption: replication right when whenever you load
Caption: up your application it's a bunch of
Caption: action and this action do a fetch from a
Caption: server and if it's a client it retrieves
Caption: on the page but it also if it's online
Caption: after it gets the start we has to store
Caption: it in local storage but if it's apply
Caption: but it's quite imagine if you load your
Caption: app in the offline position where all
Caption: this stuff has to happen for all the
Caption: action it's gonna take a while before
Caption: your redox flow is populated to your
Caption: state which means that it takes a while
Caption: before your application will get
Caption: rendered again you should use plugin
Caption: this is one that we so what it but it
Caption: does is every time your reader
Caption: straightly updated its sync with the
Caption: index dB so it's for the whole of your
Caption: read up straight index will be which
Caption: means that when it's offline it always
Caption: initialize that's for for next to be
Caption: which mean that the application is
Caption: rendered quickly while trying to do the
Caption: catching on the back end and in the past
Caption: one of the boost practice when you using
Caption: service worker is that you should tell
Caption: the user when the application is ready
Caption: to go offline
Caption: so in this is normally when the service
Caption: worker is already installed and have
Caption: fetched for the static assets but if the
Caption: tablet or computer that you use is
Caption: running out of space the OS will come to
Caption: purge some of the page and that could be
Caption: your and I think Google released a
Caption: persistent source API what that means
Caption: that if your application matched one of
Caption: this condition the con the cache content
Caption: will be stored persistently and then you
Caption: can use the API to check whether that's
Caption: true
Caption: and then you display display the banner
Caption: saying that now your application is
Caption: ready to perform right do not think fate
Caption: by yourself what do you mean by it
Caption: so use a gmail for example right sinking
Caption: step by yourself mean that when the
Caption: application is offline when the user
Caption: click on send email then your JavaScript
Caption: code check my online or not if it's
Caption: offline you display an error message
Caption: saying to user you are from the offline
Caption: please come back later and store the
Caption: email into your local storage but that
Caption: means that you require a user to go back
Caption: to your application when they're online
Caption: to sending email right again from
Caption: introduce this API for balancing so the
Caption: way you do it is once the user clicks
Caption: and you store the email in your index DB
Caption: with the state pending and then you fire
Caption: this single event and your serviceworker
Caption: will subscribe to this event and then
Caption: query all the emails from your index
Caption: will be with the state eco pending and
Caption: try to send it to the server and if it's
Caption: if it's a client then it will do
Caption: exponential back-off and if in the
Caption: meantime the network come back online
Caption: all the email will be sent so this is a
Caption: I think it's a lot better user
Caption: experience compared to you doing it Mary
Caption: King MP stand for accelerated mobile
Caption: pages it's a subset of HTML which a
Caption: bunch of prescription to ensure that
Caption: your application can be rendered quickly
Caption: to things like it has to force you to
Caption: specify imagery the source cell so it
Caption: will not try to download desktop image
Caption: if the user is pulling it from a mobile
Caption: so in the past people like to ask the
Caption: question why should I build my web that
Caption: I am here pwe right so what do I mean by
Caption: this
Caption: so if one of the pattern that people use
Caption: is they can use MPs the entry point
Caption: so you have a landing page let's say
Caption: it's a landing but didn't your home and
Caption: that is the empty page but in that
Caption: particular menu that you include this MP
Caption: what it will do it will load an iframe
Caption: pointing to your app so app d-d-duel
Caption: calm and then install the service local
Caption: application which mean that by the time
Caption: your user get redirected to the abdomen
Caption: it will have all the necessary assets
Caption: and I will render things between it's my
Caption: way the other thing that you can do is
Caption: you can load MP content and so typically
Caption: if you you fetch the data from a server
Caption: it return a JSON and then you turn the
Caption: JSON into HTML and then have the same
Caption: target rendered it will be a lot easier
Caption: if I can just query HTML and then put it
Caption: in a new XML and that get rendered could
Caption: be and that's the way you do it using a
Caption: shadow DOM yep shadow DOM is just a w3c
Caption: spec that give you n cup slept it don't
Caption: offer you a challenge of how component
Caption: that we suffered with the parent company
Caption: server-side rendering right so now
Caption: people saying that hey if I go to the
Caption: app directly it may takes a while before
Caption: I see the content so I should actually
Caption: put up so I think if you launch the dc2
Caption: instance just to do to render your react
Caption: app don't do you think that's a good
Caption: idea
Caption: so what what can you do to avoid this
Caption: right we should do a server less thing
Caption: so this is a probably applied to it
Caption: obvious but edibles allow you to deploy
Caption: your lambda
Caption: @vh which means that you can put no in
Caption: your typical if you're hosting an SP
Caption: application in
Caption: we have a cart front and that serve as a
Caption: CDN to your extreme which continued in
Caption: this doctor strainer for example what
Caption: you can do is you can put a lambda H
Caption: before that and every time you use and
Caption: make a request it grab the s3 getting
Caption: back to land it and you can grab any
Caption: dynamic content and pre-rendered the
Caption: index of that HTML before sending
Caption: sending it back to the user and there is
Caption: no server that you have to maintain in
Caption: this case right so that's just in
Caption: summary the other thing is pre-rendering
Caption: in most of the taste you don't really
Caption: need to do a lot of offensive ending so
Caption: what you can do you make the
Caption: pre-rendering part of your deployment
Caption: pipeline so after you run your unit test
Caption: after you build your application you run
Caption: headless brought to like a puppeteer
Caption: which boot up your application and then
Caption: take a snapshot of the initial page and
Caption: then injected into the index.html and
Caption: then store that into your pass storage
Caption: so in this case you don't really need
Caption: the server stop rendering at all some of
Caption: the tools that you can use to do this we
Caption: possibly we use this one because we've
Caption: worked with and we work really nicely
Caption: with the web pack shared memory and
Caption: atomic alright so javascript original is
Caption: a single single application right but
Caption: when you have a janky application it's
Caption: normally when the browser render a
Caption: sprint per second is higher than 60
Caption: frames per second and that normally
Caption: happen because you have a heavy
Caption: computation and then they introduce web
Caption: worker so you can spin up notepad
Caption: passing some data to the web worker and
Caption: then whether sending back the data but
Caption: when you work with like a big object it
Caption: it has to do a structure of cloning
Caption: algorithm which means that it has to go
Caption: to all the properties and make it thrown
Caption: out of it before you sending the data to
Caption: web worker and also the other way run so
Caption: even though you can spin up a thread but
Caption: the message passing
Caption: before between the main thread and the
Caption: worker track is correct empty so last
Caption: year I think most of the major browsers
Caption: they they introduced shared array battle
Caption: so long story short this allow you to
Caption: create the memory space and pass that to
Caption: your web worker and now your main thread
Caption: and the web worker share the same memory
Caption: space so you no longer pass in the the
Caption: pure object it's just a memory address
Caption: so what this has anything to do with so
Caption: I recommend he stopped by my Beanstalk
Caption: which is one of the meander and she
Caption: discussion with the team that will react
Caption: so I think we introduced to react fiber
Caption: version 16 well and what if that's give
Caption: you it gives you a new reconciliation
Caption: engine so if you think about react
Caption: there's a true logical part that's the
Caption: Rope reconciliation part which is just a
Caption: deep engine for the state so if we have
Caption: a new state comfortably the whole clip
Caption: and then get the bittern and then send
Caption: it into the rendering engine
Caption: so what Lincoln said there there's a
Caption: number of a proposal specification for
Caption: assembly that allow sharing of memory
Caption: between web assembly threads and the
Caption: JavaScript tracks so what that means is
Caption: you can write your reconsideration
Caption: engine in webassembly
Caption: but the rendering engine in chemistry in
Caption: reactor so you have all of the benefit
Caption: of the native code when you comparing
Caption: all the state and when you're doing the
Caption: heavy computation but the rendering is
Caption: still being done by young state
Caption: education
Caption: all right I think in the in the
Caption: beginning I mentioned that it's really
Caption: hard for the technician to be able to
Caption: type in a context password must be a
Caption: better way to do this
Caption: so luckily the pedo Alliance recently
Caption: work with major major browsers they
Caption: released this specification called web
Caption: application of web authentication API
Caption: then allow you to authenticate either
Caption: using a USB prop key or using a your
Caption: fingerprint if your devices have one so
Caption: just quickly show you how it works so
Caption: this is the so how does this actually
Caption: work it has two part the registration
Caption: and login bit so one thing that is quite
Caption: important is whenever the user registers
Caption: to the application it's for the
Caption: challenge and then the browser for the
Caption: challenge and the origin so that's
Caption: that's the domain to the Bakke and what
Caption: we generally
Caption: pair of private and public key it will
Caption: then sign the challenge using the
Caption: faculty and send back the sign challenge
Caption: public key and the key handle back to
Caption: your serving so now the user is
Caption: registered so what happened when they
Caption: log in when they log in again the
Caption: process and the challenge and then sorry
Caption: the server send the challenge and the
Caption: browser forward the chat the challenge
Caption: and the origin to the top team so if
Caption: your website is being if you're being
Caption: pissed and somebody do like a doji
Caption: website it will send a challenge but
Caption: because you're not relying on the user
Caption: to like a gluten to look at the URL it
Caption: actually the browser that's forward the
Caption: origin to your bhakti the browser sorry
Caption: the browser will afford that fake you
Caption: are alright and then that's not the same
Caption: well that you saw originally and then
Caption: authentication so that's why not only
Caption: this is handy it is also most secure so
Caption: after a check that everything is alright
Caption: again
Caption: it's signed the response with the party
Caption: and for the
Caption: to the silver and then silver just check
Caption: whether using the public key whether the
Caption: challenge is being signed for every okay
Caption: now that we have our nice pronin what
Caption: about the backend because I only have 20
Caption: minutes I'm just going to skip through
Caption: out the backend but feel free to have a
Caption: chat with me how how how you gonna build
Caption: it first of all do not use one type of
Caption: database or everything right this is I
Caption: don't want to say the bodies actually
Caption: cut 101 but that's one thing about
Caption: common sense it's not that common
Caption: so if you were to add up this website
Caption: but they literally tell you this is the
Caption: different database that they provide
Caption: Google they build a decision tree if you
Caption: write so one thing to don't think that
Caption: you you do do not use the same database
Caption: or witness and then server list is not
Caption: function as a service you can literally
Caption: build a full functioning system end to
Caption: end in a soloist way I think this just
Caption: again this is from Google just telling
Caption: you that for all of their managed
Caption: service component you can find a
Caption: corresponding several service and one of
Caption: the thing that is really awesome in
Caption: three or four seconds and you only pay
Caption: when you do the query right so that's
Caption: what that's what servers not only there
Caption: is no operation but it can scale down
Caption: with you if you work in the cloud for
Caption: long enough you know that everything is
Caption: the events they write to give you a deal
Caption: aw for example you have your extra
Caption: events you have your eventual events
Caption: your dynamo D then we need dynamo DB
Caption: eventually everything is in advance and
Caption: if you do IOT again everything is an
Caption: event
Caption: the problem with event is like in Arabic
Caption: other words have SMS and are kinases
Caption: like event streaming system we didn't
Caption: MMS even those two system doesn't have
Caption: the same specification so cloudy event
Caption: is a part of the project by the top-
Caption: foundation is try to come up with with
Caption: the specification of how do you describe
Caption: the event and that will allow you to
Caption: build a lot of tools and make things
Caption: easier and this is I think Brandenburg's
Caption: in the coupon this begin meal said that
Caption: another in order for you to deploy your
Caption: application to do beneath this we have
Caption: to learn three languages Java Script
Caption: that's your application how do you
Caption: package your JavaScript and then you
Caption: have to learn mo how do you include your
Caption: container in your kubernetes definition
Caption: right so he said that there must be a
Caption: better way of doing all of them in one
Caption: language right so this is the continuous
Caption: bid right because most of the time we
Caption: don't really care about the control we
Caption: we only care about the convenience and
Caption: this is what he proposed this is still
Caption: in beta but it's allow you to specify
Caption: your application but using the same code
Caption: dose or the time how you want that to be
Caption: deployed so this will prevent issues
Caption: things like you expose your local
Caption: container in 480 but in your community
Caption: communities technician we open port 8080
Caption: to example which because everything in
Caption: one line caught you can unit test your
Caption: application just no longer interest
Caption: after s code infrastructure or eise code
Caption: and the other thing is self illumi the I
Caption: think what they do is really smart if
Caption: you have a look at the open source
Caption: project it's just using a bunch of
Caption: telephone provider which is a goal class
Caption: will go into pest to describe cloud
Caption: resources and it used that to actually
Caption: build a robot of SDK and programming
Caption: language to type save your instructor
Caption: first code so we're ready to build
Caption: native progressive web app server
Caption: loosely so this is your typical the page
Caption: right here at your landing page written
Caption: in MV it's going to install your package
Caption: in the backend when you go to your
Caption: application everything will be displayed
Caption: straight away because everything has
Caption: been caged and user only need the
Caption: fingerprint or the USB key to login and
Caption: you have dynamic your dynamic content
Caption: storing DynamoDB your static content
Caption: from history and every time a user do a
Caption: changes in the remedy is gonna string a
Caption: bunch of events which lambda is gonna
Caption: forward to even get way that's going to
Caption: forward to Google Cloud function it's
Caption: going to store even in bigquery so your
Caption: hipster data scientists can analyze it
Caption: using a different provider thank you
Caption: [Applause]